we are here today because we are
devastated
we are angry
and we want our senators to do their
jobs
[Applause]
do your job
we are also here to honor victims and
survivors of gun violence with action
i know we are frustrated but now is not
the time to lose energy or hope
now is the time to use our voices and
our collective power
because what other choice
do we have
and that is why we're here today
our 8 million supporters across the
country are demanding to know
how many more children mothers fathers
teachers and neighbors have to die
before the senate acts
[Applause]
we are begging
begging our elected officials to do
something
anything
to address america's gun violence crisis
they
have enabled this
they are enabling gun violence with
their inaction
we know how to stop this
we know how to keep people safe while
they're grocery shopping
while they're in school
while they're worshiping
so we ask our senators who do you work
for
[Applause]
do you work for the 90 of americans who
support common sense gun safety laws
or do you work for gun manufacturers who
pad your pockets and protect your power
while over 110 americans are shot and
killed every day
take a look at the sea of red shirts
we are growing stronger every day
and we are not going anywhere
[Applause]
if i've learned anything from the
courageous gun violence survivors who
show up and do this work every single
day it's this
we will win this fight because parents
fighting to keep their kids safe will
always
out organize
at work
and outvote gun lobby executives
fighting for their profits
we will never
give up
[Applause]